so once we get to the end everyone's
gonna be finally thank God we can sleep
and then next year of course everyone's
gonna go oh we want to go back to
Belfast all right
Nikolaj coster-waldau and play Jamie
Lannister
when we meet Jamie first in episode one
he's the Kings guard he's guarding
Robert Baratheon has the king who's also
married to Cersei Jaime's sister well we
don't know in the beginning of the
episode is that Jaime also has an
intimate relationship with his sister
he's always been his father's favorite
son and he was also probably his
father's biggest disappointment when he
joined the Kingsguard if serving as a
glorified bodyguard is the sum of your
ambition go serve Tyrion and Jamie's
always had a very strong relationship
the brother beloved siblings sure he
knows about Jaime and Cersei and he's
the only one of those Cersei and Jaime
found this place where no one's around
and they have a very intimate moment
which is suddenly destroyed stop Jamie
makes a very quick decision that no
matter what this kid cannot be allowed
to tell anyone what he's just witnessed
the things I do for love
[Music]
he tells the story about why he's known
as the Kingslayer
he killed the the very man he was
employed to protect me the skin
blackened blisters melted off their
bones and Jamie's story this king the
Mad King was about to like all of King's
Landing on fire and killed
you know a million people and Jamie
killed him to stop that told me to bring
him my father's head and he turned to
experiments he opens up and he tell us
this story for the first time - Brienne
it's a very tender moment enemies
everywhere we're surrounded by traitors
your commander belongs to army now how
do we proceed no one wants to fight on
the losing side right now he looked like
the losing side the daughter of the Mad
King has arrived with her dragons and
her armies of Dothraki and unsullied
he's taking the Tyrell castle he also
has this great scene with Olenna Tyrell
where he's basically saying it's been
nice to meet you you're gonna have to
move on now will it be Payne no I'll
make sure of that
that's good she has to win this war of
words by telling him the truth about
Joffrey's murder tell sassy I wanted to
know it was me
so he has that knowledge which is
driving him crazy guess the Tyrell cold
which they need because the crown is in
terrible debt then disaster strikes
because Daenerys Targaryen decides to go
do what she does best man fly the
dragons and just burn shit-stirring
convinces him to tell Cersei to have
this big meeting there is something
bigger at stake this is not just about
you know Westeros and who's the king and
who's the queen it's about survival the
same thing is coming for all of us a
general you can't negotiate with an
me that doesn't leave corpses behind on
the battlefield they all get together
and sir she and Jamie for the first time
actually sees what all this nonsense is
about and sir she's shot and Jamie's
shot and it's so scary and now my god we
all gonna die the crown accepts you
choose until the dead are defeated
they are the true enemy yes we're in
this together and everyone's happy and
he goes in he's planning and then his
sister comes in and he goes what are you
doing
preparing the expedition north I always
knew you were the stupidest now we're
not gonna go fight those idiots did you
see that thing that's a scary thing let
them do that and we'll wait here and
then when they're done with that we'll
take them on at the start boy and his
new queen to famine off we stay here
well we've always been I made a promise
and she's like you're not gonna go if
you go I'm gonna kill you no you're not
and he walks out because she doesn't
kill him he knew that he didn't know
that but and off he goes to fight the
just cost for the world of the living
hey everybody it's Charlie I got a lot
of requests to do the game of Thrones
Season 8 promo for Jaime Lannister he
says so much good stuff during this and
gives you a pretty good idea for where
his arc is going to end during season 8
there are a couple really big story arcs
for his character couple running plot
lines that they have to bring back
around like namely him being the
Kingslayer his relationship with Cersei
his past misdeeds like pushing brand out
the window effectively starting we know
it would eventually become the War of
the five kings it was just one of the
tipping points that precipitated events
that led to that but I just love the way
that he actually talks about it himself
he's almost as animated talking about
Jamie's story as Emilia Clarke was
talking about Daenerys story during her
promo which I'll link at the end of this
but there's a new round of the Song of
Ice and Fire book giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on the video so first
big thing about Jaime Lannister is that
of all the main characters on Game of
Thrones or at least most of the main
characters the story beats that they
have to pay off that they've set up and
the previous seasons are really clear
like there's a couple characters they
could go a number of different ways
because they've changed the story from
the book so much but for Jaime's
character they're really like six clear
things that they've told you several
times and that they hit upon during
season seven again
to sort of remind you because we're
heading into the final season like hey
these are the big goals that he has so
starting with number one his desire to
be a real hero an actual knight in
shining armor because remember when he
debuted in this story he was sort of a
twist on that trope like he looks like
Prince Charming but he is one of the
worst people imaginable the next one
being his relationship with Cersei the
most important person in his life up to
the last couple of seasons I would argue
she's still the most important person in
his life but now that their relationship
has changed so much they're almost
unopposed sides of this conflict so
that's another big beat that they have
to pay off because they literally came
into the world together they probably
have to find a way to go out of this
world together the next big one isn't
finally paying off the promise of his
relationship with Brienne whether or not
they actually consummate that
relationship they had a really high
moment when he told her again at
Riverrun keep the sword is yours as a
sort of metaphor of telling her my heart
is yours the sword was more of a
metaphor for their relationship if you
listen to a lot of the commentary that
the actors had after the fact that's the
way they took that scene as well like
they have this sort of unspoken
relationship neither one has actually
said the way they feel about each other
the scene between Jaime and Brienne it
is the most reluctant love story in
history they love each other and they
hate that they love each other there is
that complication being half of a
genuine understanding of each other and
and I think that in in many ways she
gets him I leveled that very few other
people get him so they had to find a way
to pay that off they have to pay off his
relationship with bran stark because
that's arguably one of the worst things
that he's ever done so if he's on a
reverse hero arc that they have to bring
that back around when he arrives at
Winterfell and bran wheels up as the
three-eyed Raven they also have to pay
off him being the Kingslayer we haven't
talked about that in a while but it
comes up every once in a while when
people are wondering how Cersei is going
to go out because as the Kingslayer just
in a really broad sense Jaime made the
ultimate betrayal because it was the
only right decision to make but he made
the unthinkable choice because he was
trying to do the right thing and that is
completely his character during season
eight he breaks from Cersei something
that you would have previously thought
unthinkable because he's trying to do
the right thing so that's just going to
continue but they have to
to bring that back around that moment of
him being the Kingslayer
so right now there are three really
strong competing theories for how Jaime
and Cersei are going to die because of
all the main characters that I think are
gonna die during season eight they're
not at the top of the list but they're
definitely on there there's the thought
that Cersei will try to burn them all
like her signature move now her power
move is wildfire so what if she tries to
throw a wildfire over the city as
Daenerys tries to take it during another
big battle but then there's the unspoken
idea that they might try to do the
valonqar even though they didn't
specifically set that up on the TV show
they sort of cut that out from the Maggy
the Frog that you saw during season five
episode one but you can't forget the
idea of Arya's list her finishing
crossing the rest of the names off of
her list and Cersei is on her list
so if Maisie Williams has been teasing
that Arya will finish crossing names off
her list that just implies that she's
going to be involved in Circe's death in
some way but also another big Jaime
moment they have to pay off is him dying
in the arms of someone they love
literally prophesying his own death how
poetic is that so like I said you know
Jaime and Cersei enter the world
together as twins out of their mother's
womb they probably have to go out of
this world together too so of all the
deaths on the TV show I would say
probably the most complicated from a
story standpoint in them paying off
really big setups that they had in
previous seasons is Jaime and Cersei as
death but Cersei is probably one of the
biggest villainous characters on the
show so of course anything that happens
to her in the final episode is probably
going to be one of the most epic things
that ever happens on the TV show so even
though we're talking about Jon Snow
embracing his Targaryen heritage him and
Daenerys potentially having a child
together them defeating the night king I
think the stuff that's going on with
Circe's character during season eight is
gonna be as much fun to watch is that
other big mythological stuff that they
have going on in the background because
even though you have those big battles
that are happening I think they're
trying to focus more and more on the
individual characters which is why the
episodes are so much longer than normal
episodes even during the big battle
episodes dan dave and the directors have
teased that they made the episodes
longer like a big 40 minute long battle
early in the season because they wanted
to have really big character moments
with all of the main characters instead
of just getting like one or two really
big
scenes with a couple of big characters
and then you just seeing other ones walk
around in the background so of all the
big Jamie teasers and setups from
previous seasons which ones are you most
excited to see them pay off like him
dying in the arms of someone he loves
him having something to do with the way
that Cersei ends up dying him fulfilling
the promise of becoming that knight in
shining armor by sacrificing himself or
attempting to while they tried to kill
the night king and what will happen is
there's still a bunch more of these Game
of Thrones Season eight promos for
different characters so I'll try to do
as many as possible in the next couple
of weeks but leave your requests in the
comments below
congratulations to Akram Khan you're the
giveaway winner from my last big Game of
Thrones video please email me on the
about page my channel so I can get your
details click here to watch that big
Daenerys Game of Thrones Season 8 promo
and click here for all the other
character promos thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome we'll
see you guys tonight